hi guys and welcome to this week's
episode as you might remember we are
partnered with QT now QT are a social
media company and what they do is you
will be able to go on the link which is
on the comments section underneath and
it will take you direct to their website
and the beautiful thing about QT is you
will be able to talk and discuss on all
the subjects that we have explored here
in this interview without all the
nonsense of social media without all the
name-calling the shouting at each other
the boil and the nonsense so if you want
respectable discussion where you are
able to share your views in an open
environment go on to Qt the five best
comments will be starred and they will
be going up to the top and also we will
on be on there and we'll be able to
engage and to listen to your points of
view and also as well if you've got any
ideas for the channel or guess message
us on QT and by doing that we'll be able
to interact with you and it's a much
easier way of listening to your
suggestions enjoy the episode if a
conservative or a nationalist believes
in restricting immigration then someone
on the extreme end believes in killing
or deporting the people they don't want
to be there
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster i'm konstantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest this week is
a former far-right extremist who has now
a counter extremism researcher Jack bug
be welcome to trigonometry cheers /
having me on
welcome to the show it's good to have
you man before we get into like a you
know we talked about before if if we're
the mainstream media we would spend 40
minutes grilling you about all the
things that you've done in the past and
it is quite a list
I mean rightfully so rightfully so but
our sense of you having spoken with you
is that even we've done you're working
as a counter extremist now I think
you've really genuinely abandoned all
the stuff that you had but just for
anyone who doesn't know you
just give us a quick rundown of a little
bit of your life story how did you
become a far-right extremist to some of
the antics you got up to and you know
why you decided to move away from yeah
absolutely yeah well and one thing I
would say just to sort of precursor that
is that I've not become like a left-wing
liberal multi-culture this sort of you
know hippie dippie person I've not like
completely switched sides right what's
interesting I think I hope is I'm very
much a conservative you know I would be
to the right center but what's changed
is that I came from this ultra
nationalist white nationalist white
separatist white supremacist sort of
movement and that really started taking
off in the mid 2000s and yeah I mean
let's start there I was a teenager I
come from a working-class town up north
called Scala's Dale not a very mixed
race sort of multicultural town I have
to say it's like one of the whitest
places you can visit it's still very
white but the immigration we saw was
polish it woman so there was a sort of
an anger about the economic side of
things there especially during 2008 with
the crash and people started losing jobs
and then you know you've got this Polish
community that were seemingly taking the
jobs and it creates anger right so I was
like fifteen years old and I remember
seeing Nick Griffin on the TV and I
think it must have been the run-up to
the 2009 elections where they got about
a million votes and two
seats and I remember seeing him on the
TV and thinking well he's not wrong
about that you know if immigration was
too high and things like this and this
was a time when the BNP was sort of
claiming to have modernized right you
know we're not neo-nazis anymore guys
you know we just you know against
immigration and we're standing up for
working-class people and when you look
at the Labor Party who was responsible
for opening the borders in you know a 97
onwards you look at the Tory party
people from scam that never gonna vote
Tory you know that if felt like there
was no one else and so I was a 15 16
year old going through high school I
remember leaving high school the very
very last day of high school I was
leaving through the front doors saying
goodbye to the teachers and my PE
teacher asked me what you're gonna do
with your life don't literally turn to
her and said I'm joining the far right
and she went oh I know what but not the
bad far right the good far right she's
like okay best of luck another the last
time I ever saw her so then I went to
college and I it just sort of deepened
and became more entrenched and yeah I
became an active member of the British
National Party I think part of the
reason what what pushed me from just
seeing the logic of what Nick Griffin
was saying on the TV which was
immigrations too high maybe we should
leave the European Union things like
that was also I went to Preston when I
was a teenager I'd never been to Preston
before and it was the total opposite of
what's can my hometown was it was very
Muslim very non why I saw street signs
that weren't in English I saw mosques
and people in burkas never seen that
before and there's something really
emotive about that I think you know some
people might call it racist or whatever
but it's it's not a feeling of hatred
towards people it's just a genuine shock
when you see that for the first time and
I think and a lot of people would agree
with me polls show time and time again
that the British people you know have
concerns about multiculturalism and I
just think there's something really
emotive about it and when the media the
politicians far-left activists when they
all tell you that that's something you
can't talk about makes you really want
to talk about it and again I felt like
nobody else was you know talking about
these problems and then then I learned
about the grooming gang things and that
really set me off so I started becoming
an activist in Blackpool for a case
to a girl called charlene downes there's
a lot of questions about that one she
was a victim of Muslim grooming gangs
but it's late to come out that actually
the guy that or person who murdered her
we still don't know the latest
assumption is that it was a white fella
but the BMP really capitalized on that
that story I eventually left the BNP
because a anti-semitic abuse incredibly
I'm not Jewish
my step great-grandfather was Jewish he
was it came from Germany he was a German
Jew he was in Dachau came to England and
married my grandmother so I'm not I'm
not connected to him by blood or
anything but I was wearing his wedding
ring
BNP meeting in instant Helen's the first
meeting I ever went to and somebody
pulled me off about it are you married
and I was up wearing on my right hand
and like no I'm not married it was my
grandfather and I told him the story and
immediately the tone changed and I was
like ah this is interesting now this
point I wasn't really good I didn't
really know about the whole
anti-semitism thing I didn't really know
that much about the BMPs past but things
really changed and this day I've still
got these people claiming I'm a secret
Jew you know I know maybe France is not
there's a lot of people online who think
I'm a secret it's like a really amazing
thing I like that they it was awful the
abuse they put me through you know I
used to have to meet with police when I
lived in Liverpool because I was getting
attacks from communists as well as the
far-right the neo-nazis had me on the
stab on-site list it was really crazy
and so eventually I left the BNP and
then I joined part of the counter jihad
movement and to this day I've got
massive concerns about Islamism you know
I've not completely changed my opinion
on that I think there's a real issue
there that we need to talk about now I
kind of feel that maybe there's better
people to talk about it than me I'm not
a scholar but you know and so I joined
that movement and so from being a
teenager in a white nationalist movement
I became in my early twenties a gobshite
who was not a white nationalist and had
some what I believe genuine concerns
about a lack of representation of
working-class communities and things
like that but I would
I would not express myself in the best
way and I would do all four things
Channel four in my early twenties you
know four years ago or something I
handed this woman a form to taking a
Syrian refugee and told her you know I
hope you taken a refugee and I hope you
don't get raped
looking back yeah it's a terrible thing
to say I stand by the principle don't
get me wrong though there was a massive
issue at the time they would the migrant
rape crisis and I we weren't talking
about it my idea was that if you're as
shocking as possible people hate me
anyway so you know maybe I'd become the
guy everyone hates but at least we're
talking about the issue the same thing
when I stood I stood for Joe Cox his
constituency in 2016 early 2016 I think
that was and again I stood because local
people who contacted me told me about
the grooming gang issue that was
actually happening in batley which is
still something I don't think people are
really talking about in battery but I
ran a really aggressive campaign in Joe
Cox's seat and arguably I'm the reason
why the election even happened because
if nobody had stood against the Labour
candidate then there wouldn't have been
an actual election they would have just
appointed someone so I guess that's the
sort of summed up version of my history
and also you were friends with Jack
Renshaw yes so well you know it's kind
of hard for anyone already know by the
way we have viewers all over the world
it was Jack arute so Jack Renshaw is a
terrorist committed terrorist also I
think technically a pedophile
technically I can't remember whether it
was something he did when he was
underage too I don't know but yeah it's
beautiful that is an achievement I like
I'm afraid I can't offer any insight on
that bit I have no idea all I know is
Jack Renshaw was a young lad from my
hometown scam he was a couple years
younger than me we were friends and it's
kind of weird talking about him like
this because people forget that
neo-nazis aren't or weren't always
neo-nazis they were normal at some point
and Jack was very much normal at one
point and for those who don't don't know
him he tried to murder or plotted to
murder al
Lampe Rosa Cooper purely for the fact
that I think she was accessible she's
not particularly notorious nobody really
knows who wrote it Cooper and there's
there's probably people googling her now
but he plotted to kill her with a
machete and I remember hearing the news
about it and it really shocked me
because when I knew him he was just a
normal lad he had concerns about
immigration as most people do in you
know the northwestern and what's a
working-class towns everywhere really
but I just saw this gradual progression
when we were both in the BNP I left the
BNP in like 2012 or something like that
he stayed and it was really interesting
because when I was in the BNP I would
kind of parrot what Nick Griffin would
say and the leader of the BNP I would go
and have meetings with him he'd tell me
this that and the other and I'd go home
I think about it and then I pirate
basically exactly the words that he used
and I was very much sort of like a
rising star within the far-right so I
was sort of being groomed in a way I
think because I was young and articulate
and I could you know put a speech
together if I had to whereas a lot of
the young support to the BNP were
vulnerable young lads you know not
always that smart or if they were smart
they were more interested in like the
sports side of things whereas I was very
much in nerd so I was sort of it fit and
I left because of as I say the abuse I
was getting in stuff like that and and
lots of other reasons we can talk about
later I suppose but Jack stayed and he
got worse and worse than when the BNP
sort of collapsed after well 2010
onwards I suppose it started collapsing
he joined National Action which was a
terrorist organisation and he just
became a full-on neo-nazi and I saw that
progression happen and I stopped talking
to him as I saw it getting really bad
but yeah I mean that was just a really
bizarre experience and it's it's
something we're seeing all over the
world but his young lads seemingly
normal who just become monsters like out
of nowhere and you said that you
parroted Nick Griffin's opinions how did
it work this process of radicalization
because I'm sure that it works with lots
of things not just the far-right but
also you know Islamic fundamentalism how
do you go
a normal young lad 1516 to enter in this
organization - then parroting Nick
Griffin - then saying awful things how
does that process work so in I've just
written a book plug sorry monster
they're making and it's kind of an
autobiography sort of it's but it's
interlaced with you know analysis and
ideas and the argument I make in the
book is that I think there's two kinds
of people that join these organizations
there's principled fanatics and joiners
and a joiner is someone who's devoid of
any sort of ideology it's someone who's
kind of an outcast they're vulnerable
they don't have much going in their life
and they're looking for a community and
I think that works for lots of other
groups I'd say a lot of sjw's join us
but then a principled fanatic is
somebody I would say I'm probably a
principled fanatic because there was an
element of being a joiner you know I was
an outcast and bit weird and bit of a
nerd but I joined because I saw real
world problems you know I always say
extremism isn't created in a void you
don't just become something out of
nothing
and when you're a principled fanatic
it's because you have principles you see
a real problem you see grooming gangs or
you see that immigration is too high and
nobody wants to talk about that because
it's racist
and so you join pretty much any anyone
who's willing to talk about it and I did
and yeah within a few years you end up
just sort of it's snowballs I suppose
but there's another argument on mate
which is the three-pronged attack and
that is I think it's a process so it
starts with negligent politicians you
know the politicians it's inconvenient
for them to talk about certain issues
they might get dog pile if they do talk
about it so immigration multiculturalism
leaving the EU even they don't talk
about these issues because it's
difficult but those issues are very real
for some groups of people white
working-class people in particular and
so then you look to the media and you
think well the media should be that
check on the politicians right the media
should be the ones standing up to the
politicians but actually the media the
ones calling the working class people
racist and so the end you go out on the
street and when you got on the street
and you're shouting from the rooftops
it's like please do something about
these problems we care about and then
the far-left activists
break your window or something or smash
her over the head with a bike lock and
so it's backing people into a corner and
no matter whether you agree with the
concerns or the ideas that some sections
of the white working-class community
might have no matter whether you agree
with them or not politicians should
represent those people or at least talk
about those issues and because they're
not this this three-pronged attack this
process is backing people into a corner
and leaving them with nowhere to go and
most people just shut up and put the
head down and accept of this is life now
you know political correctness gone mad
and they you know they have
conversations in the kitchen at parties
you know you know under hushed tones
about it's crazy isn't it but then a lot
of people don't want to live like that
they don't have live in secrecy and so
they get really angry about it and most
of those lads end up joining the
far-right because there's no one else
talking about it and we keep using the
term far-right now apparently some
people think it's a very hard thing to
define on the Internet so what do you
when you talk about being a form of
far-right extremism what are you talking
is the far-right right okay so one thing
I always get is what bugs me I'm I'm
more in the conservative side of things
but one thing that I see with
conservatives that really annoys me and
I hope they won't get turned off by this
one who read the book is that whenever
there's a far-right attack I'll get to
the definition
whenever there's a far-right attack like
the power synagogue shootings and things
like that in America conservatives
always look to see if that person
holding the gun has ever espoused ideas
like socialized health care or something
like that because then they point the
finger and say ah he was a progressive
liberal he believed in socialism and he
was actually left-wing it's like come on
guys he wasn't shooting up a synagogue
because he was a socialist he wasn't
shooting Jews because of an economic
belief he was shooting them out of
really extreme right-wing social views
you know if if a conservative or a
nationalist believes in restricting
immigration then someone on the extreme
end believes in killing or deporting the
people they don't want to be there so I
think it's pointless talking about
economics when we're talking about this
kind of realm it's sorry let's talk
about the social values so if someone
who wants to deport all non-white people
wants to kill the Jews or thinks the
Jews run this global conspiracy
to control the West it's crazy if
they're not far-right then who is you
know so if we were gonna sort of let's
be quite overt about this if we were
going to put together a checklist for
someone who is far-right what would you
say is on that checklist anti-semitism I
would say and then an idea of not just
accepting that European people exist I
don't think that's inherently extreme I
think that's just scientific fact but
wanting to deport anyone who isn't white
was definitely going in there people who
want to kill people who aren't white
people who you know completely
authoritarianism eighteen to European
identity don't get me wrong I'm I
consider myself a culturist that means I
believe in the primacy of national
culture I believe in a unifying culture
for one nation I'm not a multicultural
but there's people who take that to an
extreme you know but yeah I mean that
would be the checklist
yeah well that's actually something that
I think you know that's a very
reasonable viewpoint that most people
are like that's my view as well you know
I think I actually get probably just
just over half maybe image actually
polls do show a majority of British
people think think like this don't ask
me to name the poll but I know there's a
few of them yeah I think it's perfectly
normal to believe in the primacy of
national culture but you just can't talk
about it
yeah but this is one of the biggest
problems that we've had with
multiculturalism being the idea that
there's no such thing as British culture
they've destroyed over time us our
ability to have a kind of civic
nationalism around what it means to be
British so I'm delighted to be British
and I've tried in my time in this
country - that's because you're actually
British that's why you're so [ __ ]
miserable all the time
cheer up but but my point is like I've
in the time that I've lived here I've
tried to adapt to British values to kind
of complain about the weather you know
all that kind of stuff like I've tried
to incorporate myself into this country
because I do see this country's having a
national identity and what has happened
over the last 20 years is there's been
quite deliberate drive to eradicate that
to make that that problematic somehow
and if you have a multi
ethnic society you cannot have a
cohesive society without an overarching
identity sorry that's something that I
think most reasonable people actually
would accept and yes I totally hear that
do you know I think that's one of the
reasons I returned to reply I think
that's one of the reasons why do you
need to be interviewed okay so you're
gonna have to move in rather to get your
words in so the I think one of the
reasons why this is again another
argument I'm making the book is that we
keep proving the far right right so when
you have this constant blatant attack on
Britishness and British identity and
even the idea that a British culture
exists I'm looking at you a for a Hirsh
when you attack that that basic idea
that a country has a unique identity and
then everyone's scared about talking
about it to the point where even like
conservatives like from the Conservative
Party are banging on about the you know
the diversity of multiculturalism is not
a strength and all this stuff
the only people talking about is the
far-right you know and if they're right
about one thing the right about under
the thing and the right and about
another thing then young lads driven by
testosterone an anger and the fact that
well logically they're correct about
some things you you can end up going to
those guys and how much of a part do you
think like this culture on Twitter and
on the internet about white males being
the problem people saying you know toxic
masculinity
you know whiteness all these different
things does that isn't that just fuel to
the fire fleas specifically so that's
the third part of the three-pronged
attack politicians ignore you media
smear you and then the far left do this
and actually the media does it as well
you know you I think I feel like we're
backing young white men into a corner
and that's kind of what I did for a
while you know after leaving the BNP I
remember I left the BNP because I there
were there were some guys in Liverpool
from the old combat 18 days National
Front and I was living in Liverpool I
was still technically a member of the
BNP at the time and I was very much on
the sort of modernizing wing of the
party you know I was in favor of
allowing white people non-white people
to join and and actually I was even in
favor of civil partnerships
the BMP was even against gay marriage
and civil partnerships you know I was on
in favor of changing that policy and
things like that so I was on the
modernizing wing of it but the
old-school National Front lot really
hated me and you know the people that
were threatening to kill me or stab me
had been in prison for stabbing people
so it was a very real threat so I was in
that world and I once I saw these things
I couldn't defend anymore and I myself
was becoming a target and I thought
maybe I made an error here I tried to
leave and I remember contacting you Kip
at the time and you Kip seems like the
natural option because there was no
chance in how a lad from scam was going
to join the Tories and so the you Kip
ended up just telling me sorry no no XP
MP allowed disavowed leave and I was
like oh okay
so not only that it was like I was cast
out of you know civilized society I was
a complete sort of you know you can't
talk to him the media would only talk to
me if it was a chance to have a go at me
and okay greatly so I was in the BNP I I
get it but this idea that you can't have
Redemption for young lads backing them
into this corner and not letting them
sort of move on from that I think is a
really dangerous dangerous thing and I
try to move on and and I couldn't and so
that's why I found myself in the sort of
counteract sorry the counter jihad world
because much of my concerns were based
around Islamic terrorism and grooming
gangs and female genital mutilation and
all the things that come with
authoritarian conservative Islam and I
still don't think a lot of what I said
was wrong
I think there is there are issues we
need to talk about but what I would say
is because I was already cast out I was
very happy to be seen as the bogeyman
you know people hate me anyway so I'll
just go and say and do awful things as
long as they created a conversation and
like when I stood for the sari I feel
like I'm going on a massive tangent here
but when I stood for Joe Cox's see that
I run a nasty campaign right it was like
I had I remember publishing images of
Joe Cox behind bars and things like that
and don't get me wrong I was obviously
not
favor of murdering Joe costs tragic yeah
leaving little kids behind and her
husband and I was awful
but my view was you know I I met people
in Batley who told me to stop
one family told me the story of their
daughter who'd been taken from I won't
name the venue but they told me a venue
in batli were a grooming gang was
operating and people have told me still
operates
she was taken kidnaps taken all the way
up north so I knew near Newcastle and
was raped by multiple men escaped
through a window and went to the police
and the police just took her home and
eventually there was not enough evidence
when the case was dropped and that's
that and that's a story we've heard a
million times over by now and the world
other people in Batman you talk told me
the same thing and when you go round
when you when you run for election you
have to get 10 people to sign a piece of
paper saying they want you to run so you
have to go and knock on people's doors
and say listen I'm standing for election
will you you don't have to vote for me
but we you and endorse me as a candidate
and you end up having to knock about 50
houses or something because not everyone
wants to do it but I'm not joking when
they say a majority of the people I
spoke to at the doorstep either their
family were victims of it or they knew
people who were victims of it and that
made me really bloody angry and you know
when I see that the the former MP no
matter what the tragedy was that
happened to her had basically ignored it
because she said nothing about it and
she was very much one of these labour
politicians who was concerned about what
what was happening overseas but this
happening on her doorstep
didn't care about piss me off and yeah
okay I run a nasty campaign and it was
awful and I wouldn't do it now I
wouldn't dream of doing it now but I
because of that lack of redemption
I felt like I had nowhere to go I had no
way of getting these sort of feelings
out and talking about them so I was like
you know what I'll just be known as an
extremist for the rest of my life and
I'll carry on doing this we've got an
exciting new sponsor haven't we
constantly yes we do it is in fact the
Economist
and The Economist is a fantastic
publication because it just doesn't just
deal with economics it also deals with
politics science technology the
environment if you want to read what
some of the finest journalistic minds
are writing about today then The
Economist is a publication for you
yeah I was reading an article there very
recently incredibly insightful into the
US Democratic primary see if you want
that kind of insight into all kinds of
things politics economics etc I really
recommend it it's been a trusted source
of intelligence for people for over 170
years so they're doing something right
and we keep talking to people and they
raise the grooming games and which is
awful I actually taught ago in East
London who was a victim of one of these
gangs and the case actually went to the
High Court
how big a motivator and a recruitment
tool is that for far right actually huge
its massive and it's it's one it's like
when I say when you prove the far right
right if they're the only ones who
wanted to talk about it and talk me
wrong more people talk about it now I
think we're getting to a better place
with this I'd like to see more
convictions but I think we get into a
better place with it now but you know
back in like 2009 oh yeah holy crap I
know buddy was talking about this and
that's that was one of the big
motivating factors for me was the case
of charlene downes so if you don't know
about this case
the media reports that she I mean it's
horrific she was chopped up and put in
talked about basically there's what the
story was at the time she was a victim
of Muslim per document majority Muslim
grooming gang in Blackpool went missing
presumed dead and the police obtained
recordings that sound like they said
they chopped her up in the back of a
kebab shop and poetic about but the
recordings are really bad quality they
might the hidden mic was put near a
television you know you can't really
hear what's being said and I encourage
anyone to go and listen to the
recordings that's probably not what
happened
but at the time it was what the BNP said
happened because the police had said it
and the politicians didn't want to talk
about it and that was a massive campaign
the first time I went out with the BNP
was in Blackpool campaigning for justice
for Charlene and it felt like we were on
this sort of righteous tirade you know I
felt like I was really doing the right
thing it was the first time I would ever
gone out to any political protest there
was this woman who she was like my BNP
mum so to speak you know it becomes like
a family she really took me under her
wing the first time I met her in
Blackpool and we went out campaigning
together and it became this sort of
community but it was a righteous
campaign for justice for a young girl
well the BNP didn't acknowledge is the
fact that those recordings were really
really awful
and the latest evidence seems to suggest
that maybe she was actually killed by a
white guy that's not negating the fact
that she was a victim of Muslim grooming
but still you know they sort of twisted
the facts because they had that
opportunity they were monopolizing on
that issue because it's not something
the politicians wanted to touch so
grooming gangs is that massive
motivating factor and it's because it
proves the far right right you know if
they're right about that if they're
right about you know multiculturalism
being you know ineffective or you know
counterintuitive or whatever if they're
right about a couple of different things
then you know why not join them yeah I
have a feeling this episode might be
demonetized
I'm sure that you refer to yourself as
British but anyway with your voice
inquisitive but it's I think one of the
things that a lot of particularly
middle-class people in London or in the
media don't really understand you know
with a story like yours is how is a 15
year old boy you might join the party
like the first National Party which
quote-unquote for the listeners I'm
doing air quotes everyone knows is a
racist party because I guess in their
little middle-class head what they
imagine is someone you know sending you
the full history of the British National
Party with an addendum detailing the
Nazi Party of you know 1930s Germany and
and World War two history when actually
what happens is you don't really have
that cause someone comes up to you in
the pub one goes do you do you want a
job and you haven't got wise because
someone taking it yeah well you know
it's not just it's you don't know that
background and stuff but actually also
even if you do it kind of doesn't matter
so you know I remember going into
college in my politics class I had a
Pakistani Muslim politics teacher who
actually got um really great with saqib
if you're watching doubt you are he was
a big fan very closely I remember he did
actually say to me when I was leaving
college like I know you're going to do
something I'll be watching for you and
he's also the one who told me you're not
the MGP at you're a conservative but I
remember after a few classes everyone
had sort of outed their political
you know you had the Tauri wing the the
class you have the labor wing yet the
Lib Dems you know you got a few weird
greens and stuff right there and I was
the only one who hadn't admitted why I
was at this point because that at this
point my closest friends knew that I was
in the BNP but I wasn't like as much of
a gobshite learn as otherwise I was I I
was really shy you've got to understand
this I was super shy which is why it's
so incredible I became so awful but I
remember the politics teacher Sahib he
was like Quan Jack who I got you got to
tell us and I'm like I remember saying
to him I went I can't you'll think I'm
racist and he was like you've got to
tell me all right
BNP and he was like yeah you're racist I
remember he went you know about the
history right and I literally just
responded yet I don't think it matters
so did you know the history yeah I knew
I know some what did you know so you I
knew that it started off as the National
Front I knew that there were allotted
neo-nazis in there but what I also knew
is I'd met people from the party and
they weren't neo-nazis some were little
old ladies you know like you might be
your neighbor they were normal people
and this is one thing I say and you
definitely demonetized
is the BNP was racist right actually a
lot of the members weren't sorry it's
true a lot of the members did not have a
burning hatred of black people some of
them would tell really inappropriate
jokes or have a [ __ ] as a profile
picture or something because but that
was mostly a finger lots of political
correctness but actually I'm a I can't
and if I can say a majority but a large
amount of people were just normal
working-class people who had nowhere
else to go
genuinely and do you think part of that
is because labor have turned their back
on them massively so yeah I mean I'm
surprised honestly that it's kind of
Labour's got no better so it's kind of
shocking the end onwards I know yeah so
it's kind of shocking that the BNP ease
kind of what disappeared really and
nothing's really properly replaced it
yet you know there isn't really a big
racial nationalist or white supremacist
I should say movement in the UK I mean
thank God but you know it could be
around the corner but but isn't that
because with brexit a lot of concerns
that people had yeah about masam agree
some of its been addressed where child
channeled into that and you had a
politician whom most people would
consider mainstream politicians neither
for us taking that issue and delivering
he killed the BMP right so so he was it
was a way of I mean and this is what I
really want to get into in in the second
part of the interviews countering some
of this extremism I mean part of it
clearly is addressing the concerns stop
making the far-right right
so it's addressing the concern so if
people had a concern about mass
immigration brexit tackled their uh
partially I mean I actually I think in
terms of what the government's doing now
we're probably gonna have more
immigration than we had before because
of the way they've they've composed at
the point system but in terms of
perception I think immigration went
massively down on people's list of
concerns because he got molded into
brexit he got folded into brexit so now
that we've had it we've kind of we've
pricked our bubble which i think is why
that racialized the way of thinking is
declined because people's genuine
concerns are at least they feel for the
moment are being addressed but that's
the problem is they feel like they've
been addressed yeah if if this new
immigration system that Boris has put
forward doesn't solve the problem or at
least look like it solves the problem
we're going to see more problems because
breaks it was like a temporary sort of
stop valve you know yeah it's gonna
start bubbling up again but you know
also another thing that I've seen is I
see the logic behind it but it just
sounds bad when Priti Patel who I I love
pretty Pathan I think she's also strong
confident woman deport you in harmony
that's what do you want well you know
she said something along the lines of I
think the policy proposal is that they
would encourage people to immigrants to
move up north rather than to live in the
London area cuz London so crammed I'm
sure people up north I mean that's the
last thing northern voters one is and
the last thing they were expecting from
brexit so I think what we're going to
see is if Boris doesn't handle this well
then there's going to be a resurgence of
something and if it's not like a stop
valve sort of skirt
around the issue party like you kit was
or breaks it was as an issue then yeah
it's something like the BNP something
genuinely extreme could you know rear
its ugly ugly head again if nobody
really wants to talk about it and I just
want to tackle this subject because we
work and I say ad nauseam in the world
kiss most liberal it's not liberal don't
say something if you say is the wrong
thing then you you get destroyed but a
lot of my contemporaries would say Nigel
Farraj is a far-right politician he's a
Nazi
could you make the case as to what Nigel
Farage actually is I was a true-blue
Tory I suppose you know it's one of the
reasons why I didn't want to vote from
I'll support him in the first place and
why I went to the BNP is because Nigel
Farage was just seen as a paw story you
know you kid were just like Tory
- Tory light maybe even Tory extra or
Tory Max or something you know
Faraj far-right I mean he doesn't meet
the quality now it'll make it made up
checklist I don't think he fits the bill
at all he's a Tory I think this is one
of the biggest problems that we've had
and we've had some issues with that
recently where if you keep calling
everyone a Nazi if you keep calling
everyone far-right if you dilute the
meaning of the term then people who are
far-right who just don't want to be
called far-right go well there's no such
thing as the far-right you just doing
what the leftist do your calling
everyone the Nazi well if you if you
want to kill Jews and deport black
people and whatever else might come on
our check list or maybe you are a nut
you know you know what I mean
and people get triggered when we say
that so I think that the misuse of that
term has been a huge problem
yeah he's problem absolutely and it sort
of allows people who are genuinely
extreme so I operate under the cover of
night you know if everyone's our
neo-nazi see this is another thing that
I think conservatives get wrong is
whenever I talk about this issue people
assume that I've conservatives often
assume that I've become a multicultural
leftist liberal overnight and then you
know I'm a traitor and all this stuff
and it's not true I'm mostly
conservative but it's still problematic
but conservatives seem to think that
I've become this little leftist liberal
overnight and it's like well
so everyone is calling everyone a
neo-nazi that doesn't mean the Nazis
don't exist and these conservatives who
think that I've become a liberal tell me
Jack why are you using that term
far-right you know the far-right doesn't
really exist it's like hang on a minute
okay they might not be in the greatest
of numbers compared to 1930s well yeah
it doesn't mean they don't exist and
this is one of the problems that I have
with conservatives on this something I
think conservatives can address it's not
something that I think is going to go on
forever I think eventually people will
realize is denying their existence is
playing into the hands of the left
because that helps them because it makes
the bright look completely delusional
when you're saying no the neo-nazis
don't exist so yeah and that it's it's
kind of like it's a tactic I think for
far left ideologues they know very well
or at least some of them do some are
just dumb but you know they know very
well that if they call everyone in the
Oh Nats even conservatives are going to
be like oh well everyone's would
movement through these days and they
just assume it doesn't exist and it
makes us look completely delusional
which is what allows the left to
dominate this narrative on extremism
right they control the extremism
narrative and that's really worrying you
know there's organizations I'm not going
to name names but there's organizations
in the UK that claim to oppose far-right
extremism and things like that and they
completely dominate that narrative and
you know they're the ones that the
politicians go to for information about
the far-right but it's run by former
members of the current apparently
current members of the Communist Party
of Great Britain that came from a
communist organization originally some
of the members doing the research for
this organisation or extremely far left
and I just find it really troubling and
worrying that the only people talking
about pharah extremism most of the time
a far left extremist that's crazy
well now that we are talking about
far-right extremism give us a sense of
how much of a problem it is numerically
because obviously judging how many
people are sitting you know in their
basements on the internet talking about
this stuff is hard but we have seen what
seems like a rise in the number of
attacks that are being committed by
these people and what
the things we talked about before is
actually you was you were talking about
how in America the majority of terrorist
attacks the result in homicides were
committed by yes so the I I'll get this
mostly right it's hard for me to
remember numbers and I'm a numbers guy
but people can check it out
the ADL anti-defamation league published
this study saying that most terrorism
was far-right in bloody party blah and
the ADL being the ADL sort of they kind
of played with the numbers a bit you
know and other organizations did a
similar thing when they released this
information and what they did was they
included homicides and violent attacks
and things from people who were
far-right extremists but the attack
itself wasn't ideological so they might
have just beat someone up in the pub
it's not far they might have eaten up
another Nazi right yeah exactly so what
some other people did I think it was
numbers from the National Consortium for
the study of terrorism something I think
that was the name of the group they
looked at specifically violent
ideologically motivated attacks that
resulted in homicide and they found that
ninety to ninety three percent of them
were far-right that's in America another
study from another group found it was
about seventy three percent so the
numbers vary but it's a majority that's
interesting
but again the other side of it is when
the realism is Islamist attack more
people die because they use bombs and
things like that and conveniently they
always start the figures after 9/11 you
know so there's that in the UK is
different story actually the number of
terror attacks and an ideologically
motivated violent acts that result in
homicide being far-right is it's kind of
low but I don't think that means we
should ignore it because it's increasing
and it's more common and you don't
always hear about it a few weeks ago a
sixteen-year-old was sent that sent to
prison for plotting to murder somebody
and finding manifestos in his room and
all these things and it was blatantly
neo-nazi there's been multiple national
action arrests what happened which at
Renshaw was really scary there was a guy
I knew when I was in this of in
Liverpool days I've talked about this
again in the book is this guy called
Darren who I remember going for a coffee
with once and he seemed kind of normal a
few weeks later I saw pictures of him
wearing a full KKK outfit and Zig hiding
and I think he ended up calling his baby
Adolphe or something absolutely crazy
these people exist they're there and to
their credit the the British authorities
are doing a damn good job of stopping
these things and so I think we need to
stop playing this game of comparison but
stop comparing it and saying oh well
remember Lee Rigby or who'll remember
the this Islamic attack and all more
people died from Islamic attacked it's a
stupid game to play because all you're
doing is admitting that two kinds of or
more than one kind of extremism exists I
stop comparing them and let's just
address the fact that it exists in the
first place and by the way not just that
the circumstances are right for a ripe
even this problem to just get bigger so
how do we combat it okay so I I think
conservatives have a job to do here but
actually I think it's more with liberals
and kind of what you're doing here is
part of that solution so so we're not
far-right enjoying my Nisha's of
Jewishness it works well for my comedy
at least no man I mean I don't know the
word liberal just like the word Nazi has
been so Mis applied yeah I mean the
people who call themselves a liberal now
then I'll [ __ ] liberal at all yeah
they're the most liberal intolerant
people you're ever going to come across
except maybe the far-right but but yeah
III I'm politically I think kind of on
the economic questions I'm in the center
you're culturally I think maybe I
culturally on some issues both of us
probably lean to the right on the
culture yeah yeah I'm so but
economically France would be an
old-school lefty so it's kind of like
that but yeah I mean having
conversations about these issues I think
is important is that what you're saying
that's part of it so I think what
liberals need to do is take the mic away
from the far left because I don't think
for a moment that these blue haired
crazy people screaming in the street are
a majority of even left-wing thinking
there's certainly not a majority in
society but they're not even a majority
on the left then we reason they have so
much control is people are terrified of
them you know I like I compare them in
the book to like an unruly dog like the
left of the owner is a nerdy unruly dog
and like they can't even live in their
own home because they're so terrified
it's going to bite their hands or
something so they just let it be this on
we thing that just gets worse and so
it's down to Liberals to take the mic
away from them and say hang on a minute
that's not us take the power away how's
that gonna happen I mean a Shaka is on
question time every [ __ ] week yeah
well yeah yeah I mean it's partly it's
it's the media is certainly a big part
of this yeah but I think more people
need to start standing up so like seeing
what Andrew Doyle does is is great the
thing with Andrew Doyle and titania is
that he does it and also it's like doing
it with a smile on his face you know
it's doing it with laughs and yeah I
think that's really powerful
seeing Lawrence Fox and more left-wing
liberal standing up to this it's gonna
be tough because they're seeing why
people don't do it you know it becomes
very difficult and emotionally draining
and it affects your life and very much
so one thing if you're a leftist if you
form a BMP it's even worse but you know
it's it's gonna be difficult but as long
as more liberals start taking the
microwave from those people that removes
a lot of the power and then as a result
of that I think the media will have to
change once the media starts seeing that
these people aren't the majority at all
but then when it comes to conservatives
I think the biggest job that
conservatives have is they have to admit
it exists thought the far right I mean
they have they have to admit that this
problem exists and they don't have to be
so defensive about it you know they can
just say we'll listen that's not
representative of us but you know we're
opposed to it too you know it's not
pretending that it doesn't exist or
trying to pretend that someone who goes
and shoots up a synagogue is actually a
liberal socialist just because they
believe in hell like socialized health
care right give me a break it doesn't
mean I do think you're gonna find one of
these synagogue shooters at a Bernie
Sanders rally like um do you think that
Boris now has a real opportunity with
embracing one nation Toryism with
winning a lot of these former were not
formal but working-class former labor
constituencies to actually really tackle
this and hopefully maybe even start to
change people's hearts and minds yeah I
think he does but I suspect he won't and
that all boils down to the fact that
it's extremely unpopular and difficult
to say whether people know this term or
not I've been saying it for years
you were a culturist you believe in the
primacy of national culture
I don't think Boris is going to say that
because it's too right it's so annoying
because I feel like if a mainstream
politician like Boris actually stood up
and said yeah we believe in a unique
British identity we believe in British
customs and values and if you're an
immigrant moving here you should adapt
to that someone says that in mainstream
politics I think that would change
everything and it would become normal
but Boris ain't gonna do that if he does
it would be great but I don't why not
but he's it's good to be the we've got
to reach a tipping point surely because
what is something most people believe
you try no the average person on the
street regardless of color regardless of
background and they will agree with it
so and he's got a mature he's got a huge
majority now yeah is he this not the
moment today it would be the moment but
this is what I'm saying I don't think
he's got the guts I hope he does but I
don't think he does and I think what
that means is if the Labour Party you
can elect someone who's not mental gonna
happen for like ten years then you know
at some point they're going to be back
and you know the you know things will
change so drastically that the white
working-class Pro won't even matter
anymore because you know demographics do
change with logical immigration thanked
and that changes the way people vote so
I think eventually we'll probably just
get to the point where working-class
parrots won't matter at all yeah I don't
think that's true at all man because one
of the things that you saw with brexit
for example is a third of ethnic
minorities voted for breaks that's true
so the idea that people are united by
their skin color or the or even the
background of immigration is it's a bit
wishy-washy like in America with Trump
for example given what he's done for
those communities in terms of employment
and stuff like that they're gonna be
actually to some extent a backbone of
his reelection campaign polls don't
suggest that but we'll see I mean I hope
I also suggest he was gonna win he's no
but my point is that just because you
know I think you're probably right there
I was born in Russia doesn't mean that
I'm automatically a massive fan of
labour but I still think I still think
it's gonna be a Mary Morris
because it's very hard in a
multicultural society to sort of
separate I know it like a Hindu guy who
is very much on my wave of politics but
he's totally like cast out from his
family because it's all they'll be
coming for us next you know though you
know they say it's just about culture
but the rebooting is out nation and
stuff so there's that fear you know and
all the people we've had on the show
from ethnic minority backgrounds they
all get called coconuts and all blah
blah blah but I also think that will
change too because there's a pushback
against now because as you say the
far-left has gone so far that a lot of
people are being driven out of that and
I think it will be it will be okay for
people not to be on the far left if
they're nothing minority well again that
boils down to I think it's the job of
normal left-wing liberals to start
speaking out against it yeah and maybe
that would aid that but I think Boris
Johnson with you know he's he's got a
really diverse cabinet and I get the
feeling that maybe there's a bit of
pandering to make make it extremely
diverse so that he's not attacked for it
I think that has happened but the people
that he's appointed seem extremely
capable to me right and so that's you
know that's a benefit and I think with
that sort of cabinet there with that
diversity of people within the
Conservative Party he's in a perfect
position to now come out as a culture
and talk about this primacy of national
culture if he did that he would reap the
rewards a bit for decades you should
talk about you no decency postboxes all
the good I'm gonna ask you a human
question now let's say a human place has
been a robotic but who's gonna ask you
human once but it's let's say because
we've all had friends well we've had
friends who maybe have started to flirt
with these kind of ideas you know you
get very angry what should you do if you
have a friend or a family member who
you've started to notice deviate to that
side of the argument oh good question
you know I think prevent is really
interesting and from what I understand
they they are quite good when it comes
to the far right and they do understand
just tell everybody I'm sorry
is the government's counter extremism
program is you know intervenes with
young people but they'll only intervene
if they're sort of tipped off and also
you don't have to comply with them which
is like that kind of sucks you know I'm
not an authoritarian so I'm not gonna
force people to comply with them but at
the same time most people are just gonna
say no thank you but when they do get
involved you know there's some great
success stories but prevent so that's
good you know what would have helped me
is and the companies have not talked
about this yet when I was in the BNP the
media onslaught against me from like the
age of 16 or 17 or something geez that I
mean that's crazy to experience at such
a young age and that again sort of
backed me into a corner which is why I
was in it for a few years and there was
an article written in The Telegraph
about me which has since been deleted
off the website I don't know why written
by a guy called Timothy Stanley I can't
member exactly what it was but it was
like a scathing piece about how awful I
was but I remember reading about it in
thinking I don't think this guy is
actually that wildly different from me
I'm in the BNP and he's not but the
things that I was talking about I felt
like weren't too dissimilar for from the
kind of things that people I came from
the Telegraph the conservative side of
things we're talking about to like
looking back I think if some of those
people on the sort of political right
because let's be honest most people who
join the far-right and never going to be
left wing some of them do have this
magical transformation and then get very
very nice careers out of being a
left-wing counter extremist afterwards
you know convenient but you know most of
these people most these young lads are
always going to be on at least on the
right and I think I will probably at
least be always center-right if some of
these people in the conservative
right-wing circles had reached out to me
as a young lad and talked to me about it
like this isn't the way to go about
things that that would have been really
helpful because the only sort of older
male influence that I had at that point
in my life because no none of the men in
my family were political they didn't
really know or care about what I was
doing because it was just completely
alien if a male conservative figure had
reached out to me and talked to me
rather than use
me as a chance to virtue signal or write
a hit piece about me that would helped
so I think I think we need to get to a
point where we're willing to forgive
monsters okay so I'm not saying if
someone goes out and tries to murder of
Rosie Cooper then you should you know
become his best mate or something but
you know the people that get wrapped up
in far-right circles we've got to have
some kind of redemption here not just
redemption but the he needs to be some
kind of intervention intervention where
people are willing to talk to them about
the issues that really care about rather
than just mocking them because mocking
them just pushes them further down that
rabbit hole and when they've got no way
to get out when there's no redemption at
all they've got nowhere else to go but
further right and when you've got
nowhere else to go but further right
you're probably going to end up in
really dark corners of the internet
you're gonna become depressed you're
gonna have no future because you can't
get normal work I certainly can't go
normal work and for most people that
there can be life-ending so you more
likely to go out and commit one of these
got nothing to lose now look the one
question before we ask our final
question I wanted to talk to you about
is something again we discussed before
which is how do you deal with these
ideologies in the public space because I
asked you on the phone I said do you
remember Anna Griffin going on question
time and the argument that I've been
persuaded up by up to this point was
well he goes in question time I guess I
think he'd probably say he wasn't
treated fairly no he definitely wasn't
I'm right and I think I'd probably agree
with that he was he made it the Nick
Griffin show as you put it they picked
on him a lot instead of just letting him
contribute on an issue just like any
other panelist yeah but my my thinking
up until that point the you and I had
that conversation was well look he goes
on question time he sounds like an idiot
next year there's an election party
share plummets he goes bankrupt
brilliant victory for free speech yeah
right but what you said to me was
actually the next day the matter
membership showed up the amount of
traffic to the BNP website
shut up massively so is there than an
argument I guess that the left the far
left makes which is by platforming
certain people you're giving their
ideology a oxygen that shouldn't be
given it's not just platforming them
it's demonizing them the fact that they
made it the Nick Griffin show and they
attacked him so much was why people
joined and why people went to the
website and why people were interested
because it was such a blatantly highest
show I all they did was you did this you
said that and yeah okay some of the
accusations obviously would I mean he's
done awful things you know he was
appearing with David Duke in the KKK and
all this stuff and so rightly so but
there was some other things that were
like some people might look at and go
well isn't he right about that you know
we should control immigration and so
when they see those not smearing going
on the second part of the three-pronged
attack when they see that happening they
relate to it and they think we'll sod
everyone else sod the mainstream I'm
going to join him membership shot up
there was a point around that time were
at least this was what the BNP was
saying or the BNP webmaster was saying
that actually the BNP was the most
visited political website in the world a
political party website in the world was
huge
it has gonna reign for a thousand years
it was like this website I remember I
had a peak oil section it had all these
membership forums and the forums were
hugely active right the top was a
picture of Nick Griffin like this it was
huge and there was this huge online
platform and question time didn't kill
the BMP what killed the BMP was a
combination of things really it was
mismanagement from within the party
accusations of corruption this is the
boring stuff that I saw from the inside
what really killed it was Nick Griffin's
vanity he kept you know he was very much
seen as he's got to go because he's got
this much baggage and they were at that
that tipping point where they just won
two Emmy pees a million votes they were
mainstreaming we've got to get rid of
this dude who's been with the KKK and
we've got to get someone younger in and
that's why they were groom young lads
like me cuz eventually we've become
leaders of something but there were some
other contenders in the party who were
considered more moderate who were going
to sort of take the reins if that
happened I think the BMP would still be
here right genuinely I think it would
still be around and
it would have been a competitor to you
Kip if they'd have continued down that
modernising streak very much like the
National Front in France you know the
National Rally is called now with marine
lepen right it's amazing how you can
turn a party from you know being led by
a genuine raging anti-semite so now a
mainstream political party that comes
second in the presidential elections so
yeah I think that I think all right so
but answer my point which is the bad
platforming yeah it's it's an argument
that I haven't spoken to you about it I
now I'm like what's the right way to
deal with this for them platforms so
platform them and treat them fairly so
yeah because people like if you if you
don't treat them fairly then it it it
creates right again it proves the far
right right there's a Jewish conspiracy
to you know like kill whitey and you
know to control this cent against
multiculturalism and things like that
and when you kind of do exactly what
they're saying is happening it bothered
you bit um you know then it would prove
them right have them on TV let them say
their things but you know at the same
time if you're gonna platform them you
also need to have politicians in the
mainstream who was saying talking about
the issues that working-class people
care about so it's not just a matter of
platforming them it's you could the
probably an argument that if you
platform them then it mainstream's them
right but if you counter that with
mainstream politicians who actually
address genuine issues that on about
hating people because of their race it's
things that affect working-class people
like that the the changing nature of
working-class towns and the changing job
market in working-class towns like where
I came from it was former mining town
and now it's like a warehouse town
everyone works in the warehouses and
stuff but you know there was a huge as I
said Polish immigration that sort of
shifted that when you talk about those
issues and then you're mainstreaming
like the far right people are going to
go with the mainstream one and also
eventually the far-right are going to
become insignificant anyway because the
mainstream people are talking about it
is just like don't starve the far right
of oxygen starve them of the issues when
you take away the things that they're
right about they left with pure
conspiracy theory the only thing they've
got left is that oh god that on the Jews
awful and they're controlling everything
the
don't associated with that because it's
not true well it's interesting that you
say that because as you know we've been
dealing with a few people trolling us
from from the far right yeah
and this is where they're like demanding
that we interview the you know their
favorite neo-nazi and all this kind of
stuff common tactic yeah but I actually
I don't think that it's not about
platform it's just we're not a show that
debates people yeah you're not you're
you don't owe them anything and also the
reason they say that what they usually
say is they trying like the you know ben
shapiro
yes service if in america they always
say to him debate I'm gonna Nick
Prentiss or something like to debate
this person to rate this person and it's
like hang on a minute Ben Shapiro has
got this gigantic audience and then the
smaller sort of neo-nazi crowds I've got
sizable issue audiences but we're
talking thousands not millions who
benefits the most from that debate you
know some of these people in the
far-right are so done that you can
absolutely destroy them in a debate and
they still think they've won like it's
crazy
either they're dumb or they just do it
anyway cuz they are done we were just
talking about this they have this theory
that the Jews have conspired to replace
white people with Muslims and Muslims
really get off this is the one thing
like it's so crazy you know this is I
always pull them up about that ya know
it's it makes absolutely no sense but
you know they they III think a thing
with the far-right is it
it offers here's another thing right so
yeah okay my answer your question you
don't owe them anything you don't need
to debate them and the only reason they
proposed those debates is because
they're the ones who benefit the most
from you and they say they win
regardless of what happens and then
suddenly they've got access to when she
appear as millions of viewers no but
also I think while we're talking about
these sort of like Nick Fuentes people
who's he's like a white nationalist
youtuber before he got banned off
YouTube I think I think we banded he I
hear I don't I'm not a massive follower
but I heard something maybe in fact I
don't know I don't watch the show but
one thing I think is really interesting
is he's gaining some young people know a
majority or anything like that it's
nothing crazy but it's it's substantial
and I think it's because
the far-right is perceived to be fun and
that sounds weird but when okay so
you're a young lad and you're figuring
the world out right and you see real
world issues about immigration
multiculturalism you know you see the
Trump agenda is actually countering this
crazy far-left sort of Puritanism
it's not very Punk anymore like the
leftism Punk anymore very much church
ladies and they're always complaining
about something and this is sexist and
this is racist and here's what you have
to say and you can't say that so you've
got that option or you've got these
dudes on the far-right who are doing
these YouTube shows and laughing about
everything they're having a load of fun
compared to those guys and so when
you're faced with these sort of
competing factions these extremist cults
which cult you're gonna choose the one
that's telling you what you can and
can't say or the one that says say
anything we don't care it's hilarious
yeah you know that's I don't know how
you address that pure it is omit isn't
very attractive is it you know pure
realism that's not that it's not that
appealing but look thank you for coming
on the show we wish you all the best or
the counter extremism work appreciate
it's a really good book monsters of
their own making we recommend that you
get it and read it thank you what's your
Twitter all the rest of it twitter is
just Jack buck BB you see kby yeah
website Jack buck video cut at UK and
the book is called monster of the row
making and yeah I do hope you'll pick it
up fantastic now it's available on
Amazon and all good bookstores now on
April 28th but you can pre-order it now
thanks for the stuff thanks for coming
on the show and we'll see you guys in a
week from now with another brilliant
episode take care
and I'm delighted to find out that well
after all these rumors we're not far
right we'll see you next week guys
thanks for watching guys has always
subscribed to the YouTube channel click
the Bell button next to subscribe button
so you get notified when a video comes
out and follow us on all the social
media add trigger pod and also leave us
a nice review on iTunes and spread the
word